[Applause]
this video contains the answers to my
four revolutionary riddles so if you
haven't seen the riddles yet you should
probably watch them before you watch the
answers it's okay I'll wait just click
this card up here now when I filmed the
riddles I also filmed the solutions at
the same time but that was before I
received your 15,000 comments and dozens
of video responses so I'm reading parts
of this solutions video to incorporate
the results I saw in the comments and to
use some of your video responses to help
explain the solutions let's get to it
okay by looking at the comments for
number one over fifteen percent of you
said a cylinder containing sand now this
contains some powder see how it rolls it
it doesn't seem to roll very far before
it stops and then it won't roll again
because I think the sand just kind of
levels off in there maybe you were
thinking a bigger kind of sand like this
small gravely stones let's try that
that actually rolls pretty well nearly
25% of you said a cylinder half-full of
water so let's try that
this rolls very well and so it's not
water and nearly 45 percent of you said
a cylinder half-full of a viscous liquid
here I have a half-full container of
honey so let's see how it rolls that's
not bad it's rolling and it's it's
stopping and it's rolling some more this
is a pretty good guess and I think the
behavior is not exactly the same as the
mystery cylinder but it definitely is
similar and that's no coincidence the
mystery cylinder actually contains honey
and ping-pong balls there are two
ping-pong balls submerged in this honey
so if I place that on the ramp and the
center of gravity is not above the point
of contact with the ramp and so it rolls
forward but now because those ping-pong
balls are in the front they change the
center of gravity and so it's exactly
under the point of contact and so it
stops briefly but then as the viscosity
of the honey allows those ping-pong
balls to move up the center of gravity
shifts forwards again allowing this
little container to roll so that is the
trick of the mystery cylinder pretty
easy if you want to try it out at home
now I challenged you to run two laps of
this track where the first lap you could
go as slowly as you like but the second
lap you had to go much faster such that
your total average speed was twice the
speed of your first lap now when I was
first asked this question by Simon Pam
Perna
it took me a long time and scribbling on
paper and just something didn't seem to
work out and that's because you can't
actually do this it's impossible I mean
you might think I could run 3v1 for my
second lap and that would mean my total
average speed is 2v1 the problem is you
can't just add the two velocities
together and divide by two because you
spent much more time
your first lap so that velocity is
weighted more heavily into the average
so you'd have to run well impossibly
fast let me explain the velocity of the
first lap was the distance around the
track divided by t1 the time it took you
now if you want your total average time
to be twice v1 well then it needs to be
2d over t1 you need to run twice the
distance in the same amount of time as
it took you to run the first lap but
you've already run that first lap and so
you have no time remaining to run the
second lap even if you went the speed of
light you would not be able to increase
your total average speed up to twice the
velocity of your first lap it is just
mathematically impossible so this may
seem like a bit of a trick question but
the point to me is how doable it sounds
how it seems like something you should
be able to do but you can't it's it's
actually impossible riddle number four
the question about the train was
actually answered pretty well with most
people mentioning something to do with
the wheels but of course that makes
sense in a series of riddles which are
about rotation rotational motion some
people though did point out that maybe
it was the steam that was going
backwards or maybe air molecules in the
Train and that is actually a pretty
clever point however I wouldn't really
consider it the air in the Train part of
the train so indeed the part of the
train that is moving backwards is the
flange part of the wheel which is below
the rail that is the part of the train
which is moving backwards to understand
why you just think about a spinning
wheel the top of the wheel is moving
forwards at speed 2v and the bottom of
the wheel is not moving forward at all
it is stationary with respect to the
track and that is what we call rolling
without slipping and that's how most
wheels work at least that's how they're
designed to work now in the case of
trains they have to have flanges so the
train doesn't fall off its rails but of
course when these pieces come around
during the rotation of the wheel they
actually extend beyond the rail and
therefore they are going backwards with
respect to the ground so the part of the
train that's moving backwards
is always changing but it's always that
part of the flange that part that
extends beyond the wheel that is below
the level of the track so what happens
when you pull the bottom pedal of a bike
backwards well about 45% of you thought
that the bike would move backwards about
a quarter so that it would move forwards
and a quarter said the bike wouldn't
move at all and 5% said it depends on
something so let's give it a shot and
see what happens I'm going to pull
backwards on the bike pedal in three two
one whoa the bike did indeed move back
and for virtually all bikes this is what
you will find but the explanation is not
just as simple as well the net force on
the bike is back so therefore it has to
accelerate backwards and to prove that
that logic doesn't work we'll just have
a look at this video by George Hart
what's this
again I pull the same pedal backward but
now the bike whose forward I'll put a
link to the full video here and a link
to his website in the description so the
reason the bike moves backwards is
because of the way these gears are set
up the diameter of the tire and also the
distance on this crank to the pedal
itself because as a bike moves forwards
the pedal even when you're pushing back
on it never actually moves backwards
with respect to the ground it's always
moving forwards so if you drag a string
behind a pedal of a bike moving forward
the string is always moving forward now
just play that movie backward in your
mind and it may be clear how pulling the
string backward could make the bike move
backward they move forward together so
they move backward together another way
to think about this is to consider the
path traced out by the pedal as the bike
moves forward this is called the
trochoidal ordinary bikes and the pedals
are moving much slower than the tires so
the pedal is always going forward with
respect to the ground but George
modified his bike so the ratio of the
pedal to the wheel radius was greater
than the ratio of the front sprocket to
the back sprocket and this ultra low
gear changes the trochoidal does
go backwards with respect to the ground
as the bike goes forwards and that's why
he could pull back on the pedal and make
the bike go forwards this is the same
reason why if you were to pull backwards
on the flange of a train wheel you could
actually get the train to move forwards
if you pulled backwards with enough
force for all normal bicycles pulling
back like this on the bottom pedal will
cause the bicycle to move backwards but
depending on the gear ratio you can get
the bike to move forwards so it was
those people who said it depends on the
ratio of these gears and the size of
this crank to the radius of the back
wheel that were actually the most
correct
you